gears here to talk about our weather
it's friday nice temperatures but i'm
keeping all my windows closed because of
the weather outside yeah you saw that
fast cam we showed you it looks bad out
there yeah i almost wanted to use that
fast cam as my background but i have so
many tower cams that are showing that
haze last night when we're doing the 11
right it looked like fog it sure did
right but it's not fog that's all haze
that's all coming from this california
wildfire look at that wow
smoke all right live look outside again
all our tower cams are showing this guys
air quality advisory remains in effect
right now and that's going to be lasting
through today will it get extended
through tomorrow that's not up to me
that's up to clark county so we're going
to wait and see what they say right now
though things will improve a little for
the weekend
i think the denser smoke was yesterday
but you can see smoke and ozone still
reporting moderate readings right now
currently outside 97 for sky canyon
centennial hills same for you 96 for
north las vegas 95 for the east side
sunrise manor 94 whitney ranch 95 for
henderson 91 from mountains edge 96 or
southern ireland so still a little warm
out there
but wait until you see what's in store
for us
next week 90 for indian springs 87 for
searchlight 97 for laughlin 105 still
for death valley that doesn't surprise
me still hot out there lower innovation
out there in in yolk county so here's
what's going on believe it or not there
are actually storms south of us like we
saw yesterday south county mainly into
southeast california see these complex
of storms here in baja and southeast
california that's from that low that has
developed and as we take a closer look
they have flash flood watches there in
southeast california this is where we're
at look at where these flash flood
watches are okay not in arizona this
time this is all in california let's get
a closer look at the storms south of us
they're drifting from east to west very
isolated though and they're not lasting
very long there's where we're at we're
dry so while we have the hazy skies here
you look to the south you'd see those
clouds but you can't see those clouds
because the haze is out there here's
your nascar weekend forecast big weekend
for not only this raiders
aviators lights everything 95 for
saturday 92 on sunday now we're looking
at mostly sunny skies i put these 10
percent chances are out there because
there is a slight slight possibility we
could get a stray storm to move up but i
think really all of it's going to stay
south your winds also will stay light
it's going to be a nice looking weekend
tonight 72 degrees hazy and cool mainly
light winds your high for tomorrow 95
degrees mostly sunny and warm 92 is
where we should be so we're still going
to be right around those mid 90s for
tomorrow and also for sunday but take a
look at next week all right we'll have a
cold front slide through that's going to
increase winds i'm going to step out of
the way here and show you the numbers
each day will get cooler after monday
and we're looking at mid 80s now for
wednesday and thursday that's below
normal and still in some 80s also on
friday next week i like it a lot that's
your most accurate forecast christian
over here i'm not complaining